un oficial del ejército ruso llama lista
los reservistas llegaron a la base
militar rusa de Samara cerca de la
frontera con kazajistán y se preparan
para luchar en Ucrania en sebastopol
ubicada en la anexada crimea al sur de
Ucrania los hombres enlistados en la
armada rusa se despiden de sus familias
estaré protegiendo a mi patria y a mi
amada familia para que haya tranquilidad
en el mundo y nuestros hijos puedan
dormir en una situación normal
pero la opinión de esta madre contrasta
con el entusiasmo de ser gay
mi hijo que no sirvió en el ejército que
no tomó clases militares que no tienen
nada que ver con el servicio militar Y
nunca ha tenido un arma en sus manos ha
sido movilizado
una prueba más de las denuncias hechas
sobre el llamado a hombres inexpertos en
el campo militar y ancianos el propio
kremlin admitió que ha cometido errores
en la movilización de los 300.000
reservistas cuya cifra real también sin
duda
inconsistencias que aumentan el temor
entre la población rusa desde el anuncio
de la movilización el flujo migratorio
de rusos hacia Georgia se duplicó Denise
de 34 años oriundo de Sara ya está el
lado georgiano de la frontera
este hogar es justo vas a la guerra y no
tienes miedo pero cuando vas a pelear en
una guerra estúpida para matar a tu
hermano la gente
el Ministerio del interior prevé la
instalación de puestos militares de
movilización en la frontera con Georgia
para reclutar a los reservistas que
intentan salir del país